what you doing okay okay
roll roll it out roll it out all right
we are back we have refreshed our
afternoon links yeah this is like
drunken baby cookie we call her pokey
yeah that's like her nickname I feel
like that's what a couple of people have
requested shirts I've heard so I can
work something out yeah yeah
well like I said I feel like I'll do a
little cartoon with no detail yeah but
yeah so cookies down there wanna do [ __ ]
so on this last segment I wanted to talk
a little bit I I know that I said that I
wanted to do like [ __ ] about Nibiru and
[ __ ] but I thought we already did we we
kind of talked about that a little bit
on our like end of the world prophecies
type of thing so I feel like maybe on a
day we do new bureau we also haven't do
something about [ __ ] Prometheus and
alien covenant because that's a Nibiru
ripoff story really well maybe wait have
we done like a review of those movies
yet we have not so maybe when you do a
review of those movies we don't worry
about that yeah but I do want to talk
about the Black Knight satellite very
because I just wrote a big long article
about this yeah supposedly something is
up in the orbit around the earth it's a
mysterious satellite yeah and this
pretty much I have the alien yeah I have
to say that this came from as far as I
know a single NASA photograph that
looked like it had something in it that
sort of looked mechanical and sort of
looked like a spaceship or a satellite
or something and people perceived it as
that and then I feel like people kind of
went back in time and like looked for
other [ __ ] to you know kind of lend
credence to the whole idea that there
was a Black Knight satellite word the
story come from was there some contrast
mission or a photograph or a rumor where
did this [ __ ] like I said I think this
story of you know the the codified story
the Black Knight satellite came from
this particular photo but I'm
start at where the Black Knight
satellite conspiracy theorists say that
it started from which is Nikola Tesla
okay
now I'm going to say that so Sputnik 1
was was which was the first artificial
satellite obviously which anyway whose
hey oh my goodness pulling stuff out of
the damn this kitty she's like she's
like a child own stuff out there just
eat it yes so 1957 so the Russians put
Sputnik one into orbit which was the
first artificial satellite in orbit and
I feel like after that it was kind of
like all bets were off like everybody
started putting satellites up and [ __ ]
like that now as of 2019 it should be
said there are over forty countries of
the world that have put you know at the
time about eight thousand artificial
satellites which were once in orbit
around the earth
not all of those are still operational
or functional only about five thought
five thousand of those are still in
orbit three thousand of those have
fallen back to earth
less than two thousand of those are
still operational meaning these are the
ones that control your GPS you know and
all the other kind of [ __ ] that they
control yeah there's an old Divo the
very first one has some one they're
called space junk yeah and that's
exactly what's up there nothing you
wouldn't be surprised people you'd think
that it'd be hard to get some up at
orbit you know or that there's you know
a bunch of [ __ ] up there in orbit that's
what I mean like ants and my dog it's
old it's now space junk well yeah like
only a quarter like okay like look at it
this way only a quarter of what was
initially launched into orbit as
satellites only a quarter of it is still
operational yeah the other
three-quarters of it jump is generally
just space toys he
falling back to earth er it's just
floating around Oh out they're useless
there's stuff up there they forgot about
yeah like I said they're not big like
you know in relation to you know the
vast nothingness of space it's not
really that big a deal so they just kind
of like leave it or but I don't know
there's all kind of like crap up there
so the kind of theory started to grow
over the years like I said particularly
after this one photograph that came out
from NASA that there was like this kind
of alien satellite up there but let's
kind of start at the beginning so we
weren't starting at the beginning well
we are but not like I said it's in this
conspiracy theory is kind of complicated
okay right it didn't come about until
this particular NASA photo okay but
after this NASA photo came out everybody
like backdated [ __ ] to like be support
for this particular photo you know I'm
saying yeah so I'm kind of trying to go
chronologically yeah so like I said
let's go back to Nikola Tesla so Nikola
Tesla as everyone knows bad ass
scientist you be the home to like
wireless communication stuff like way
ahead of his time and whatnot so 1899
he's at his lab in Colorado Springs and
he's working on the technology that
would eventually go into his
Wardenclyffe tower which would
eventually be built in Shoreham New York
now while he's going about this task he
gets this weird radio signal which was
um unusually regular so now he was used
to getting radio signals that were kind
of like strange that would come from
various earthbound phenomena such as
electrical storms or other kind of like
you know other things that he could
account for but this one he thought was
a little unusual because it was very it
seemed like very regular like someone
something that was coming from an
intelligent source more or less what
year was this 1899 okay so now initially
he thought well this seems like an
intelligent transmission
he presumed that it might have been
coming from Martians this was eight nine
1899 yeah he said you know because
people believe that people lived on Mars
and that was common knowledge that was a
fairly you know that wasn't a weird tack
to take at this point even if you were
Nikola Tesla yeah so he thought oh maybe
it's Martians um so the weird thing
about it though is that even though
Tesla got this transmission which he
supposedly thought was from Martians he
didn't think it was enough of a big deal
to like stop what he was doing and get
back on that [ __ ] like it you know what
I mean he's like he's working on his
wireless transmission thing it's like Oh
some aliens have contacted me yeah [ __ ]
that just don't even answer it like he
didn't attempt to replicate you know the
the signal he didn't attempt to do
anything like that he was just like oh
yeah and he acknowledged it was maybe
Martian yeah but you got it Tesla is a
contemporary a [ __ ] Lovecraft Trey
okay they're into weird [ __ ] might event
you know might be aliens it might be
people from another dimension it might
be people from my old ones from [ __ ]
deep underneath the ocean they don't
know so there's but you know this be
honest about it though Tesla was a
promoter I mean you know he he likes to
say crazy [ __ ] in public he said a lot
of crazy [ __ ] he did yes made a lot of
crazy claims although he was not an
idiot that dudes genius yeah he was
definitely not he was just having fun
yeah so I feel like even though he did
say oh yeah maybe it's Martians he might
have just said that like to get some
publicity yeah because the fact that he
said oh maybe it's Martians and then he
was like man whatever I'm going back to
what I was doing
yeah cuz I know on a side note you have
you have him saying he thinks he's
getting signals from [ __ ] aliens back
there in the space race they had some
guys I was the Marconi brothers sir who
was a guy from Italy I think yeah they
supposedly picked up a transmission from
what they thought was a Soviet no
Marconi was I think of
they were the ones that invented like
the whole radio thing I thought it might
have been Martin the Marconi brother
Marconi or some kind of brothers got it
what they thought that they had
intercepted a message message from a
Soviet I would say scans or something
about that the other day and and they've
got a recording of it although I can
find that I would play it yeah of a
woman [ __ ] speaking in Russian and
she sounds very panicked and evidently
she's saying it's getting hot in here
it's getting hot in here yeah that's
some [ __ ] terrible [ __ ] imagine that
like she's coming and burning in or
coming into the atmosphere because I
don't know it during the space race the
Soviets lost a lot of rockets they did
yeah and a lot of astronauts and they
[ __ ] hushed it up because we didn't
hear about all their failures failure I
mean just like everyone else they don't
want failure could have been they put a
woman up in up in orbit before Yuri get
your your Karen was up there and
possibly these guys that could be but
also that it's regular sorting it is
very creepy yeah I've heard it but like
that transmission could have come from a
lot of different places and it could be
a hoax it could be a hoax it could be a
lot of different things
it is creepy sounding though I will try
to find it because I was just watching a
documentary about that the other day and
I'm like it is a creepy recording
sometimes it was the Marconi or their
Marconi brothers I don't think it was
that wasn't though it's just the way I
remembered it it was some Italian guys I
think yeah that's how I remembered it
that was like you just associated heard
I tell you guys that messed with radios
yeah so the thing about it is like I
said Tesla was like even though he told
the press it's like yeah maybe it's
Martians maybe they're contacting me
whatever it's like he didn't really deem
it important enough to like stop his
work in other areas like I said he was
working on radio transmissions wireless
transmissions other things of that
nature and he didn't really think it was
all that important so he didn't want to
like stop doing some other [ __ ] to focus
on that so the thing about it though is
that in later
years it does seem like probably the
transmission that he got could have been
from a pulsar which is something that
they didn't know about in 1899 as the
first pulsar was not observed until 1967
it's possible yes so and and you know as
most people who know anything about
astronomy or you know anything like that
know pulsars the reason they're called
pulsars is because they emit pulses of
electromagnetic electromagnetic
radiation in a regular pattern that
seems to be like a communication but
it's just because they rotate in a
particular way
yeah and it's a super regular pattern
within like a [ __ ] second right so so
if you had got that in 1899 then yeah I
I could see that's not crazy to think
that you were getting that from an alien
civilization because there was nothing
else like that it's like who else would
be transmitting a signal like that other
than somebody that was you know that
knew what they were doing guys they
didn't know what two pulsars were so
most modern astronomers have theorized
that the weird signal that he got was
probably from a pulsar because like I
said pulsars were not observed until
1967 but it should be noted that before
this happened was almost 40 years before
this happened in 928 it was actually
another guy in Norway and his name was
Jurgen halls he also got some weird
radio transmissions now he called these
LD YZ or long delayed echoes now these
signals they didn't really know what
they were at the time they're not
entirely sure what they were now what
they are now but they thought later on
maybe that these signals could be coming
from an alien satellite this was
actually proposed by a dude named Ron
Bracewell who was a professor at
Stanford at the time so they called them
Bracewell probes
so he said that these aliens that he
proposed that these alien satellites
were like outside of Earth they had been
picking up transmissions from Earth in
them bouncing them back and then coming
back so that's why there was like a
delay in the time period so this was
later this was kind of like back dated
to support the Black Knight satellite
theory because this was something that
weird transmissions that they didn't
know what they were at the time and they
still actually don't really know what
they were like yeah but it's like so a
guy at the time proposed oh maybe there
was an alien satellite that was bouncing
the transmissions back to earth and that
bad thing that's why there was like a
radio delay and so maybe this was the
Black Knight satellite so this is
another thing that's that kind of comes
into play as you know something in
support of that theory now also in 2017
Stephen Hawking had a thing called the
breakthrough initiative which was a
program founded in 2015 and this was
supposedly for the purpose of picking up
you know evidence of advanced alien life
now in August of 2017 they said that
they had got some unusual radio signals
and some people speculated that maybe
these signals were coming from an
extraterrestrial source but it should be
noted that they're not really sure where
these came from it's like these could be
like regular like I said from a pulsar
from a magnetar from a supermassive
black hole there's a lot of different
places this could have come from so it
doesn't necessarily have to be an
intelligent source but this is another
thing that people are like pointing to
is saying this is the Black Knight
satellite and this is like it's making
intelligent you know transmissions now
in the 1950s there were two newspapers
San Francisco Examiner st. Louis Post
just sent Louis post-dispatch
there was a guy named Donald Kehoe now
he had been in the Navy he was in an
aviation major but he was also later
became an UFO researcher he said that
the Air Force had discovered two
satellites of unknown origin that were
orbiting the earth this in the 1950s now
when they discovered them supposedly was
three years prior to the Soviet Union
but launching Sputnik one so this is
1954 so he's thinking their satellites
up there before that yes I mean there's
a possibility you might have some rocks
up there because during the formation of
the earth there are things or the or
actually the earth can actually pick up
satellites you know you have a meteor
going by and instead of it falling into
the earth and burning up somehow finds a
perfect orbit those that don't find a
perfect orbit fall in or move away from
the earth those that do just hang in
there just hang out so there could be
you know yeah that if something comes at
us a rock a glancing blow and just
enters orbit perfectly and if it stays
it will stay well hopefully and you'll
see a if it didn't stay it won't stay
and you'll never see it so we're talking
about the ones that stayed it's a chance
that something could be captured called
a captured object yeah yeah that's
possible yeah of course yeah
now at the time they were kind of
worried that that this could be a Soviet
spy satellite as you would be worried
about right but I should it should be
noted that um now this article in
particular said that Donald Kehoe said
that another guy who was secretary at
the Air Force Harold Talbott said that
he knew about these two satellites that
they had seen and also that he had seen
several flying saucer
on several occasions now
Talbot later came out and said no I
never said that I saw about but this
kind of like story about the satellites
like sort of kept going on now Donald
Kehoe would later go on to become he was
like a UFO researcher so he would kind
of go on to become like one of the main
you know components of that whole you
know scene and everything so he's on
like the board of the National
Investigations Committee on aerial
phenomena which is called NICAP and
stuff like that so he also wrote a book
about UFO sightings so some people have
kind of like discounted his claims on
that score because they're like oh he
was just trying to sell his UFO book and
maybe that was a bunch of [ __ ] so
you know there's that whole thing now it
should be noted that there is one other
corroborating source for the two
mysterious satellite story and that is
the Venezuelan communications ministry
now a few years after dal Kehoe
supposedly said that the US Air Force
had these saw these two mysterious
satellites the Venezuelan communications
ministry also said that they had been
tracking Sputnik which had been lunched
by that point and they said that while
they were tracking that they saw these
two other mysterious objects which they
didn't know what they were and they said
the reason that they caught their
attention was because they were orbiting
in retrograde now at this stage Sputnik
had only just been launched like only a
year or two before so it's like some
other satellites have been launched in
the interim but not really that many but
the ones that had been launched
none of them orbited in a retrograde
moving like from east to west so they
said that stood out to them so the fact
that these two were moving in that
fashion like kind of you know made them
stand out to them
so that was another like Robert and kind
of thing so that was another thing that
kind of made Black Knight satellite
people be like yeah maybe that's what
they were talking about what did you do
strop don't worry about okay he's
dropped something okay now let's move on
to the 1960s now in 1960 Time magazine
publishes a story and they said that
they have discovered an unknown dark
object - that is in polar orbit around
the earth and the US Navy said that it
was probably a Soviet spy satellite now
the Department of Defense comes out and
says no it's not a spy satellite it's
just like some leftover debris from the
u.s. from the Air Force Discoverer 8
reconnaissance satellite that had broken
but orbit so they weren't super worried
about it
long-forgotten satellites yeah but of
course like UFO researchers were like
yeah we don't believe that [ __ ] now
three years later 1963 Gordon Cooper who
was an astronaut yeah he saw a lot of
[ __ ] he did UFOs yeah yeah so he's
completing his 15th orbit of the mercury
Atlas 9 space mission now reportedly he
saw a UFO that later accounts said that
was monitored by other tracking stations
like on earth now this is supposedly
another you know kind of evidence in
favor of the Black Knight satellite
theory although it should be said that
the mission transcripts if you've read
the mission transcripts that were
produced by Gordon Cooper at the time
that were produced by Manasseh at the
time don't say that he saw this so this
might have been a later interpolation
okay now in relation is when something
goes
back in the record and yeah and put
something in there because Cooper later
said that while I was on the mercury
nine mission I didn't see anything weird
now that's not to say that Gordon Cooper
is not into UFOs because even though he
said he didn't see anything on that
particular mission when he bird is on a
biography later on he saw all kind of
[ __ ] he saw he said he claims he filmed
some UFOs yeah that had landed yeah yeah
at Edward airport it was Air Force Base
yes he does
he's into UFOs oh yeah he said that the
first one he saw was in West Germany in
1951 while he was like flying you know
in a military capacity United States
Germany Cooper he is an astronaut he is
slightly weird I was a bit weird yet he
seemed weird to me Who am I to say what
he didn't see didn't see that yeah and I
mean in his autobiography he said that
he saw he not only said that he saw a
craft land at Edwards Air Force Base in
1957 but he also had a bunch of other
like anecdotes of like stuff he had
personally seen over the 1950s other
astronauts that too so he put all that
so he wasn't like a verse of the whole
UFO thing he would add that he saw a
bunch of stuff he went on the more I
remembers a little kid remember Merv
Griffin he went on the I saw him on the
Merv Griffin Show and somebody hits Merv
Griffin have brought up something about
UFOs and I can remember Cooper going oh
well I don't I don't discount that
they're like what he goes oh yeah we see
what we see stuff yeah and you know what
recently they're coming out the military
is coming out well yeah we see stop me
yeah Cooper even in 1978 he actually
went before the UN like he did like he
testified form the UN and he said that
look I've seen UFOs like I know dudes
that have seen UFOs he didn't say
they were real but he said you guys
should take the accounts of them more
seriously well he said they were real he
didn't know if there were an
extraterrestrial
he never said yeah he just said that
they should be taken more seriously than
that that a lot of them are or some of
them are yeah yeah so there was that
whole thing too now where the Black
Knight name might have come from and I'm
not sure if this is true or not but in
1964 the British Ministry of aviation
they had a project that was called the
Black Knight satellite launcher now this
was part of their larger Blue Streak
missile program which had started in
1958 now that was actually a rocket that
was called the Black Knight rocket and
it was used to test re-entry vehicles
although the larger program that was
called the Black Knight satellite
launcher project that apparently never
put anything into orbit so I'm not sure
if this is where the name for the Black
Knight satellite came from or if there
was some kind of overlap or something
because this program at least as far as
the British government has said has
never put anything into orbit so it's
not like this is the source of the
satellite or anything but you know I I
wonder if this is maybe where the name
of it came from because it's kind of a
cool name Black Knight satellite that's
kind of a cool name but so that might be
where the name of I came from now 1973
this is where a lot of the kind of
legends about the Black Knight satellite
kind of begin to codify so there's this
guy named Duncan Lunan and he is a
Scottish researcher and he had been
studying the same delayed echo radio
signals that your ghen halls had been
listening to back in the 1920s
so he's studying those same
transmissions now he
that he has figured out the
transmissions and that these
transmissions had come from a planet
which was thus far undiscovered that had
been orbiting a binary star Epsilon
Bootes or butis or something yeah
absalom booty Epsilon booty we'll just
call it that booty so he says that he
translated this alien message and it
read start here our home is Upsilon
booties yes I'm just gonna say it like
that I know that's not gonna be booty
epsilon booties electronic booty that's
a that's where all the big booty a Leah
exactly just like in laser blast with
the turtle interesting with the big
butts
exactly yeah that's where those aliens
come from yeah so epsilon booties which
is a double star double except one fries
one on the sweat sheet yeah we live on
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all right
so okay what's the time we're fine just
don't worry now I wonder how much is 25
minutes oh that's okay 25 it's alright
you got doing about another 20 minutes
yeah
we live on the sixth planet of seven
coming from the Sun which is the larger
of the two I don't know what that means
yeah our sixth planet has one moon our
fourth planet has three our first and
third planets each have one our probe is
the position of Arcturus known in our
maps so is the alien this was supposedly
the message of the aliens that came from
epsilon booties yeah so that's the
message we sent out back in the eighties
through that the one with it yeah yeah
did that be a better idea of what a
[ __ ] civilization would send you you
were saying I mean yeah a picture your
DNA yeah we're not smart but like we do
know that legs okay let's just do so
let's not presume that other people
speak the language so I presume let's
let's show them like a mathematical [ __ ]
yeah a typic sit looks like [ __ ] how
big they are antenna is and stuff like
that that does seem a little right it's
very suspicious like well now I do feel
like if aliens are trying to contact us
that might be one of the first things
they would say is where they were coming
from yeah
so that's not crazy but I don't know no
I don't know well like I said I don't
believe this whole blackness the only
thing I'm just saying that right now so
now let's talk about this sort of this
this right here is where the whole black
net satellite thing like came about like
I said the other [ __ ] that I was talking
about was kind of like backdated to fit
in with the Black Knight satellite thing
and this was the sts-88 mission and this
was in 1998 this came from the Space
Shuttle Orbiter Endeavour and this was
the STS
mission they were going up this was the
first American mission to go and work on
the International Space Station and this
was where the Black Knight satellite
thing came from because one of the
photos that came back from this
particular mission showed what appeared
to be like it looked like the earth and
then it was like this thing in the
foreground that looked like it might be
like a wall spaceship or a little
satellite or a little something you know
I mean it looked like that so that's
where the whole thing came from like I
said all the [ __ ] about Nikola Tesla and
stuff that was kind of like backdated to
like fit into this kind of narrative
right so the story starts with a find
this this voters vote and like I said
that's really when it starts seriously I
feel like there is a hole okay so maybe
there's like a whole like subset of
people and I assume it's all dudes that
sit there and like look at thousands of
NASA photos and they just look for this
is like the same type of people that
looks oh look at the face on Mars
right oh look it's a rat on Mars or it's
a woman or whatever the boy was in the
photogenic okay so the photo kind of
looks like like I said I'll show the
photo in the video the photo looks like
it's earth yeah and then there's like a
thing and it's like this ambiguous
little black object okay it may be it
could be a satellite but maybe could be
like a million so this is the beginning
of the black light very much satellite
story they find a photograph of the
earth with something there yeah and
they're like what is this that's s lying
to it alright so what happens again
it's a lapse so I feel like okay now I
feel like what this could be
and some experts have weighed in on this
and they looked at the photos they you
know looked at the whole context of the
situation of what was going on and they
said probably what that is like nobody
knows for certain okay so don't get
excited but I feel like what
that could be is that okay so the crew
that went out there with the endeavor
yeah that we're working on the space
shuttle that we're working in the
International Space Station they had to
do some EVM which you like outside they
had to go outside and like work on the
[ __ ] face walk yeah um
at one stage they think they might have
dislodged one of their little like it's
like I was like a full thermal blanket
it's a black cover yeah it's like a
blankie but it's like it's solar
facility shiny super shiny blanket yeah
and they feel like they might have like
dislodged that and then like it kind of
went flying over there and they couldn't
get it so this this [ __ ]
blankets in orbit of super blankets yeah
so I kind of feel like what this
photograph is and a lot of experts have
looked at it and said this too it's like
this might be this blanky
right except they just captured a photo
of it because if you look at it it kind
of looks like a shiny blanky but only
you know like one side of it is kind of
shiny and yeah there's a second thermal
blanket like it so yeah that's exactly
what it is kind of like tinfoil look
like tin foil aluminum foil oh yeah
because it has like that like it that
gold kind of shiny yeah way you can make
it real thin and it keeps you yeah it's
actually called a trunnion pin thermal
cover okay yeah so they feel like
probably while the endeavor was working
on something like outside of the
spacecraft that they made of like
dislodged this blanket and like kind of
knocked it into space what you're saying
so what you're saying is that the Black
Knights the Black Knight satellite is
probably just space junk probably Jeff
it was a blanky a thermal blanket got
sucked out the airlock
not even sucked out the airlock it was
like it was outside it was wrapped
around something that was like outside
or working on and then it came off and
they couldn't get it right yeah
some floats off when you're in orbit
you're not gonna go out there and get it
that's what I mean is like oh well we
have other yeah you can't just swim your
way through space I don't care what the
Japanese will tell you remember
that movie space scene yeah they were
swimming through space
you can't swim through space and look if
it views I'm not going on into space
without like just to get a blanket we
have more of those if you don't have
anything any kind of thrusters on you if
you lose physical kind you're not tied
to that ship if you lose contact with
that [ __ ] ship you're gone there's no
way to get back to that ship that's what
I mean you would be home every day I'm
your host yeah that would be I can't
really imagine much worse deaths than
just fun a space is just floating out in
space and just knowing that there's
nothing that you can do and who knows
like you would live out there for quite
a while probably here right now until
you air ran out until you died a thirst
and do whatever yeah and it's like that
would really not be a pleasant way to
die yeah and the ship could be with
could be just right out yeah right out
of your reach there's no way to get to
it right there and that's why I like
sometimes when I see sci-fi movies even
shitty ones like from the 50s and I
think I've seen it alike the mole people
or maybe is amol people are no it was
the Phantom Planet that's not a thing
that where like a guy like kind of falls
off the ship then he floats off in his
face in a way that that feels like the
worst kind of death to me because it's
like one your salvation is like right
there but you can't get to it and two
it's like you know that you're gonna be
alive for a long time you just may float
in there there's nothing yeah it's not
you there's nothing you do though and
it's like that really bothers me which
be weightless and it wouldn't feel like
you were moving either I'll just be
flown out in blackness a bunch of stars
that would suck come on see the earth
below you in a way and I'm gonna admit
this right now even like this song even
the the [ __ ] Space Oddity song by
David Bowie yeah yes even that kind of
bothered me because it made me think
about like if you weren't like if you
got blast out of your capsule or if you
got you know if there was some kind of
accident then it's like there wouldn't
be anything you could do about it and
for a long time
you would know that there was nothing
you could do about it and you knew that
you weren't gonna make it
like they couldn't bring you back to
earth they couldn't do anything to help
you so you would just be like floating
out there and you'd be like yeah yeah
it's uh no that would be that's one of
the worst fit that is a face where fate
worse than death I think so so far it
sounds like the Black Knight satellite
is just a [ __ ] like I'm gonna say wrap
here blanket that was around I feel like
like okay this is not proven they don't
know if that photograph was actually of
the blanket or not but most people that
have looked at the photo and most people
that have like kind of looked into the
issue about like you know the endeavour
and like their whole thing about it
they're speculating that what you were
seeing is probably just something that
came off of that shuttle or something
that came off that mission and just like
kind of floated in space probably a
thermal blanket just because it's kind
of reflect on one side and they're like
that's probably what happened you're
seeing that in a one particular
photograph and it kind of looks like it
could because I've seen the photograph
and it looks kind of like it could be a
satellite or something mechanical and if
it's not that there's a myriad other
space that's what I mean so I feel like
there's stuff up there forever
I feel like this whole thing kind of
came about because somebody somewhere
saw a picture of a blanket floating in
space and then was like you know alien
technology and then they went back and
put a story author because like I said
all the stuff about Nikola Tesla and
Jurgen halls and all that other kind of
stuff that wasn't necessarily related
the plot to the Black Knight story until
later that was like a back dated like
when people were looking for oh well
other evidence of like alien contact
prior to that that might have been
attributable to this row purported
satellite that's floating outside but I
don't know because if an alien satellite
was floating just outside of one we
would have seen it by now
- what would they be doing there like
why do they care
who needs detective if it was
transmitting and that's what I mean and
the thing about it is that I'm a big
advocate of like look I'm not denying
that there's aliens out there but there
probably are but it's like one why would
they give a [ __ ] about us - even if they
did give a [ __ ] about us why would they
be monitoring us it's like why would
they give a [ __ ] about what we were
doing really well I mean why would they
give a [ __ ] in a depends on scale it
depends on what they were I mean yeah
someone like Park Rangers they might be
modern to monitor us you know I I think
maybe some of them are watching us but I
don't think that this Black Knight
satellite is PAH is possible in terms of
aliens lay its face chuck it is - aliens
would be a lot more advanced than that
yeah it's like if they wanted to watch
us they can totally do it a lot they do
a lot better ways way than some way that
we could detect I think they found a
picture of space junk and then like you
said they went back in the record and
tried to find stories to explain well
it's just kind of like that whole the
whole oh there's a face on Mars and
there's a rat on Mars this sudden the
other it's like people have nothing
better to do clearly then monitor every
single photo that NASA puts out and they
look for some anomaly that looks like
something that could be interpreted as
something else it could be that it's not
necesarily they have nothing better to
do it's what it is is that they're a
part of some kind of group that wants to
come up with a cool oh that's you again
so they go back and look through there
and they find this picture and they go
what's that oh well let's go back in
time we can connect to this yes someone
is clearly doing that yeah that's what
it is someone with more time in their
hands than I have heard of it I never
really bought into it
I really don't either like I said this
was something that I did I wrote a long
article about recently just because you
know I was commissioned to but it's
something that I feel like this is one
of those things that it's like it was
just one of those like anomalous it's
kind of like the face on Mars
it's like some anomalous photograph
someone saw it and made a big deal about
it but then like you see later
photographs of the same area out there
and it doesn't look like what normal
yeah it just looks like a normal hell
like did the only reason that it looks
like face was because the resolution it
doesn't look like anything if you see in
like a higher resolution so I feel like
that's kind of the situation here I feel
like that somebody found a photo that
looked kind of anomalous and then they
built a narrative around it right to
just and then wigs in time and like
found all these other justifications for
like kind of making this whole they kind
of elaborated this whole like story
about this whole thing and I feel like
it doesn't exist like you know what I
mean I feel like it's not there it
sounds weak to me - it really does yeah
all right so we are probably drunk as
[ __ ] yes Saturday night is Saturday
night you this drunk on show
really never seen you this drunk oh I'm
still talking talking yeah you're
talking but I can hear it it's been
about three hours yeah I know no we
don't normally go that long well I've
given you what two or three drinks I
given you like three big wow this is the
third yeah three big ones yeah you're
holding it together you gonna be alright
Jenny I always go read it together even
pokies hold on together look at looking
baby cookie behind them on baby cookie
has not had any liquor sold it together
I'm not giving her like her yeah but
yeah the thing is it's like I feel like
I'm still like seriously I've pneumoniae
whatever the [ __ ] yes you sick this is
he knows yeah it's been a weird I got
much sleep yeah
oh we gonna have something like that so
the fact that I'm still fairly coherent
that's amazing
you thank you for acknowledging that
fact once you're going to shut it down G
so I'm gonna shut it down right now
hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
extra long extra drunk show 13 o'clock
we're just like talking about I don't
even know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about we're talking about space
conspiracies
moon-landing hoax all this kind of [ __ ]
shut it down don't shut it down well I'm
trying to like try to rev up to shut it
down no no I'm trying to like look I'm
trying to like throttle down this is why
they didn't leave a blast crater
throttling it down you have to like ease
into these types of things like look do
you want like look what I'm doing a
colonoscopy do you want me to just like
stick some [ __ ] up your ass or do you
want me to like ease into it just stick
that [ __ ] alright so with that lovely
alright we're gonna end the hundred
fifty of episodes like I said extra long
extra drunken episode hope you guys have
enjoyed we'll both be all right
hopefully like I said it's it's Saturday
night we're gonna sleep and hopefully
people are coming tomorrow to paint the
rest of our house yeah watching people
are people are painting the outside of
our house today yeah so and tomorrow
they have to finish it it's gonna be
alright
so we'll see how it goes well yeah it's
Saturday night so hopefully you guys
have enjoyed the hundred and fiftieth
episode remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on our social media
why are you laughing at me being cute
cute dress don't worry about it's gonna
like share and subscribe way yeah like
share subscribe yeah that's what I said
oh no I'm not interfering okay I'm just
laughs it's cute as [ __ ] go ahead like
share subscribe
if you would like to financially support
the show we would appreciate it greatly
you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
or you can get our blog 13 o'clock
podcast WordPress comm and there's a
little button in the sidebar which goes
to a PayPal account which goes right to
our little PayPal account which is lady
o one-time donations want to do that you
do that if you know like patron for
whatever reason remember we have regular
episodes come out every Tuesday our
movie retrospective it's usually older
movies comes out every Friday and we
also have 13 o'clock matinee which comes
out every Sunday that's usually three
movies in the theater that concent every
Sunday and if you are a patron then you
will get to see everything 24 hours
before before everyone else you know if
you want to feel like special they are
they are a special that's why when those
[ __ ] videos goes up there's over any
comments on them because the patrons
have commented first yeah I put those up
24 hours and like I said if you want to
see the [ __ ] early you can see the [ __ ]
early if you become a patron only have
to be like a [ __ ] buck or something
if you want to do that yeah if you don't
want to do that that's cool too but if
you want to do that if you much
appreciate it helps us you know do [ __ ]
around the show make sure it's do all
that kind of stuff so you know if you
want to do that that would be cool too
and that will do it for this long drunk
sort of painful episode of a hundred
fifty eight hundred fifty of them so you
made everything go blurry podcast we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]